[Music]
my secret is about my mother who is
about 75 years old now
a few years back she started showing
signs of memory loss dementia suspected
to have alzheimer's disease and
kind of been painful watching her kind
of slowly slipping away over the last
few years she's still relatively
coherent can have a conversation to some
extent with her but it's not going very
well now and it's only going to get
worse going forward and something i
don't tell her and don't tell really
anyone else is that
for her own sake and also for the sake
of those around her
sometimes i wish she would kind of just
pass away in her sleep
or some other quick and painless way
relatively soon instead of having to
endure
kind of the slow fade
of this illness that she's got it would
be impossible for her to actively choose
an early death or a quick death
but on some level i think she even knows
that it would be better for her and
also you know a little easier on the
folks around her so
it's not easy to say it and i don't like
thinking it at times but sometimes i
wish my mom would just go ahead and
peacefully pass away
soon rather than
hanging on and lasting too long too many
years into the future
[Music]
okay um my secret is that i was sexually
assaulted when i was 12 years old and it
went on for about four years and no one
knew about it and because of that
i'm very sensitive to touch and emotions
because
i didn't i was not able to process my
emotions during that time since i was so
developing
and i wonder how i would have grown up
if that didn't happen to me
[Music]
i was assigned to male at birth but i
don't feel like it
and i'm afraid to tell my family
because i might be rejected
[Music]
my secret is i love my dad more than my
mom
and even though my dad wasn't available
for me growing up
him coming back into my life a couple
years ago has meant much more than
spending my whole childhood with my
mother even though she did
provide a lot economically but she was
never there emotionally and
yeah
so i have an entire extended family
including a father
grandparents and a set of twin brothers
who live in new mexico and
never have i met them or
really have any idea who they are
or anything about them and
i don't know i wonder if they maybe even
know that i exist
but yeah
[Music]
so i have a crazy secret i found out
after 18 years of living i'm adopted so
i found out after 18 years my dad told
me brandon you have a sister and so i
started on instagram and i tried to
search for her he didn't know where she
was none of my parents knew where she
was but i knew i had a sister
so i finally found her
um on instagram and so i dm'd her and i
was like hey i need to talk
and then her boyfriend dm'd me and said
uh like off
my boyfriend dm'd him and said that this
is her by the way
my boyfriend dm'd him and said like
don't like don't message me don't make
friends don't mess with my girlfriend
hindsight he he liked all of my
instagram pictures like messaged me at
like 11 o'clock at night saying i need
to call you i had no idea who he was
like she was he felt threatened it was
very random but in my head i was like
i'm about to meet my sister and i didn't
even know that i had any siblings i like
had no idea i knew i was adopted but
didn't know i had any siblings so i knew
i was adopted but i didn't know i had a
sister so we found out
that we were related in san diego and so
we met at a starbucks and then my
long-lost brother at starbucks it was
super cool so this is us uh we met at
starbucks
starbucks yeah
and uh
this is our third time ever hanging out
we're here at pablo park kind of crazy
and it is crazy kind of crazy it is
crazy
so
yeah should we should we high five or
sibling high five
siblings
so when i was a kid from like five to
fifteen
i truly and honestly believed that if i
thought and willed it hard enough i
could turn myself into another animal
and so like i would lay there in my bed
my parents would think i'd still be
sleeping and like what i thought was a
cat position and i'm like if i just
think it hard enough and imagine myself
like growing a tail
growing ears like transforming then i
would legitimately
suddenly open my eyes and be
my goal was you know like a tiger cub
that was that was big but i think
looking back on it as a kid that was
kind of my
escape from
everything that was going on in my home
environment i was like if i can just
turn into a tiger and escape my life
would be perfect so i don't think i've
really shared that with anyone because
it's kind of silly but also like i don't
know wouldn't everybody want to be able
to shape-shift into animals or maybe
that's that's just me
[Music]
you still do that sometimes or not i
mean
maybe the fact that the entire week i
was wearing different animal costumes
for halloween speaks to the fact that
that desire is still there but no i
don't try and transform anymore
at least not that way
my secret is
i used my last year's tuition to travel
the world and i never told my mom she
thought i was in college the whole
entire time
i did graduate but instead of taking
four years i took five years and i told
her that it was because i had a master's
program
so i last talked to my mom when i was 12
and i wonder if she is still alive
whether or not she would recognize me
i'm 32 now
[Music]
my secret is i've been single for five
years i'm going to be 30 soon and i'm
scared that i
will never find somebody
[Music]
my secret is my brother is my best
friend in the whole world
why is that secret
just because i don't think i've ever
told him but i really think that he's
the best person ever
so
i'm a woman has
over two years of sobriety in my life
and it's been the biggest blessing
but i guess it's not really a secret but
something i've been holding on to is i'm
so deeply worried
about my brother because i feel like
he's in you know a place i was in two
years ago and that was a really dark
place and
i get worried that
one day he'll decide to take his own
life or something like that or hit a
rock bottom that he can't spot can't
bounce back from because i was
i was there and i know that dark place
my secrets are never really secrets
because i'm always willing to share if i
think it'll help another
i was born under a tree in a desert
there were no others except for my
mother and my father
my mother was very brave
my father too
and then
there were three
i've always had gratitude for the trees
three and a half years ago i stood at
this tree i was nine months pregnant
i didn't know at the time
but the baby in my belly had already
deceased and passed on
during the photo shoot
i have pictures
at this tree and all over this park
decked in white
beautiful
graceful
hopefully
the still birth
was very compassionate
i did it at home
by myself
i asked my partner to leave the room
i would break up with him two weeks
later
i've rarely told anybody but
as i pushed that baby out
i got clarity
that i would leave him
and i did but as i root my feet to the
earth
as i hug this tree
my heart is full
i know that this life is divinely led
and that baby
that i buried
under a beautiful olive tree
she was an angel
a spirit too high for these realms
and me
born 40 years ago
i was born
to love the trees
and my senses
and openness
the possibility
i may or may not have those screaming
children you might hear in the
background
of my own
but my senses and something i've never
told anybody is that i have a
responsibility to mother the earth
we're all put here for a reason or a
season
and sometimes our lifetimes are short
of gratitude
gratitude
gratitude
that is why i still smile and laugh
and live my life as full as possible
thank you
i love you
you are loved
my name is eve
[Music]
hey everyone for those of you who are
new my name is thoria and i'm the girl
behind the camera make sure to subscribe
and hit the notification bell so you'll
be notified every time i have a new
episode up and follow me on instagram
i'll be posting more on there as always
thank you guys for everything i love you
all and i'll see you next time
you